welcome to this video playing I'll carve
FML car from Israel ok I've got played
them two times already two wins so let's
see if this guy can stop the bleeding
thought hmm interesting I don't know
this too well the grid felt fianchetto
always thought that this is believed to
be a better for wide isn't it but not I
don't really know how I mean don't know
the lines may be 97 85 coming ok but
this runs into a temple with Bishop f4 I
don't know this is so great ok I like to
get this in ok what is this miss Rooke
chewing on before and if I go a three
hmm I wonder some some tactic or
anything hmm
I really thought this is a move that's
useful anyway so this is a bit weird
maybe look-see for is this idea and
tending Bishop c2 but I thought looks
you one would be good maybe I can allow
me to capture here if he takes Queen
takes I mean this whole procedure was
certainly in my favor I believe Queen on
c1 helps Bishop age six and i'm
attacking c6 directly not sure but yeah
maybe he can play an active move like
three day five just playing actively
okay Queen takes I guess maybe 90 for
some active move this is the Greenfeld
after all where you give up aunts
everywhere to get to get your pieces
active is in fact he's playing that I
wonder Queen a5 is irritating really a
move like bishop age six would be
attractive in general get this exchange
but you can play can play a queen 85 if
I take on d5 what is the catch here
Bishop deform maybe
defaults also attacked it's got the
screen f5 coming hmm somehow lack like a
bit of time here in this position grawr
effect no no no no definitely not I'm
just thinking here maybe this is an idea
taking on e4 Bishop takes Bishop age 6
ok this is a very unconventional
solution but maybe it's an idea I is
taking with the pawn of course
immediately remove that and not not even
vaguely considered ok now then let's
just play this position I only consider
to take with the bishop of course ok
admission page six now I mean he does
not really want to make me here right
this is not working ever I really think
so maybe i'm wrong but i don't feel he
can make me with this little pieces left
this is a very nice structural advantage
now I just need to make sure he's not
getting any any sick counterplay Queen
III maybe just just queen III on this
this looks we had it to hangs I can also
check you for directly this is probably
i'm probably simple and good
the d1 rock is unprotected this is maybe
the base for some tricks but nothing
that concerns me too much here I was
really surprised that he took with the
pawn okay I'm just night takes I guess
takes rook checks and I have 93 possibly
next to cover them look on d1 there's
also Queen g5 maybe something like that
at f6 is also that f6 is a funny move
here King takes Queen e5 made this looks
very nice yeah that's very nice move if
he moves the g4 Hanks also i can maybe
I'm I rookies see unprotected so maybe
he can still play the Queen somewhere I
can then of course taketake e5 but it's
not not made or anything but not f6 is a
skewed of course
King takes Queen e5 is a very nice made
okay is there's some better move then I
probably not especially considering the
time situation just f3 or what should i
do should blunder the rook definitely
maybe f3 it's got 30 seconds left
just try to keep keep control him rupee
five maybe maybe d5 was was an option
check time warning check check I can't
go he can go to Italy I leave this is a
bit this is a bit concerning
some way from me to cover this I'm not
sure
I didn't see this actually that you can
take them check I'm really losing the
threat yeah this is hanging wow what am
I doing here check check check
oh man sound good and getting in there
what the heck is happening here oh okay
check check round wrong game I'm just
I'm just a [ __ ] here but what the what
the heck out of this come on how did I
allow this counter play with Queen a6
services this is not not so clear
look a five I can play and then we get
seven of course as it should be should
be winning really easily chair after all
that yeah okay let's briefly go back to
the moment where to Connie form which
was an interesting interesting way to
play I'm really only only reckoned with
this and then bishop age 6 okay the car
is giving wider substantial at 0.5 the
idea was that right here if he goes for
this this I have 95 which is very nice
so but he took here and this is may be
very better Queen d5 given by the
machine may be around yet definitely
definitely is favoring white with the
better structure this is just bad here
but should reform I think I played it
okay I mean all this was nice but I
really screw this up at the end
amazingly okay thanks for watching